tell me about this look what's a secret
so I just really wanted to go for a lot
kind of a Jessica Rabbit I provide so
yeah she's like one of my favorite
cartoon characters so thank you
incredible incredible year for you are
you able to like head into the holiday
season and be like you know what I
crushed I did no I did I did what I had
to do we had a hot girl year we still
dragon wall oh yeah what do you think of
there's that song like wolf club or
whatever and they did they made the song
hot hot girl bummer happy thing what do
you all do it
your girl knows those performing tonight
live oh she got nominated for so many
Grammys when is the collaboration coming
between the two of you we're already
working on some stuff so I'm super
excited boys come on next year we're
really putting off for Houston right now
so listen now that you are a superstar
everyone wants to know if you're dating
and I know that you shut down the Trey
rumors so what are you looking for in a
man right now I'm really not looking for
a man but if I was it'll be somebody
it's super funny and he has to be tall
[Music]